I am getting slammed on our reddit
discussion forum I'm gonna show you in a
second some of the discussions we now
have over 2,000 viewers of the show or
soon to be over 2,000 just shy of 2,000
of your show viewers participating in
our discussion forum on reddit you can
get there by going to david pakman.com
slash reddit that's our EDD iti hope
you'll subscribe there let's go through
a few of the discussions that are going
on some really good discussions and also
a lot of slamming of me one topic that
was brought up was do you think Trump's
election will ultimately be better for
the progressive movement this is
interesting and I've talked about this
and this is a nice long post making the
case and you can check it out I have
suggested that had Hillary Clinton won
the White House but Republicans still
controlled the House and Senate there
would be less urgency among progressives
to really activate in the way that that
we need to and I hope that we will so I
think there's something to that to that
and you can discuss that on our ready
discussion forum another post from our
ready discussion forum argues that
actually the mass deportations that
Donald Trump is proposing could actually
happen and they go on to cite historical
data to discuss that it is very
interesting and I would encourage you to
check that post out on Reddit and
participate another post from our reddit
discussion forum Trump is selecting some
of his transition team advisors in
ignorance of what they are about when
they start advising him he'll fire them
I've been wondering about that which is
that Trump is putting some people on his
transition team that seem to have
different ideas than the ones Trump
stated during his campaign so there's
sort of two possibilities one Trump will
get rid of them because he'll realize
these are not the Republicans that agree
with his ideas or two he'll just be
convinced by them because Trump seems to
go with whatever the most recent person
who spoke to him said so I don't know
but an interesting conversation
nonetheless also from our edit
discussion forum this relates to the
bonus show david when a cat is showing
you his or her belly they don't want to
be padded i suggested that i really
don't trust cats because very often
whenever they seem to want me to rub
them i start rubbing them and sometimes
it's the belly and next thing i know
getting all scratched up is that true
Pat you have a cat is that not a sign
that the cat wants you to touch its
belly when it exposes itself and lays
flat on the ground it totally could be I
mean with cats you have to build up a
trust with them uh it's not like dogs
will just love you no matter what yeah I
guess I just don't know enough to even
know what the hell is going on when cats
are seemingly trying to get me to touch
them and I think we have one more post
from a reddit discussion forum uh
another thought here it seems like David
is really losing it lately I won't read
that one to you but it's fascinating and
it's getting a lot of attention on our
reddit discussion forum so head over to
david pakman.com slash reddit re d di t
check out what's going on there and i'm
on their daily participating pat is as
well